alright guys we are at ti7 we've got
memes
we've got slack the sexy blonde chick
[Music]
thank God tons of great dota and if
you're not here tomorrow go back to the
League of Legends okay well I don't know
why did that are opposed they they are
playing extremely well the t-birds
department I think you look at newbie
they of course if you want to go keep up
with that Chinese go to action it is of
course on other stream sell for streams
going on be sure to check it out don't
understand you stopping to chat ka PPA
press and to hold down alt and for it
will take you straight there
funky well look at the shell was cut SOG
oh oh yeah
dr. Joe Joe pendant I Sally to TP s is
not pass to your SE suniye toasting also
corporal painting Chelsea go go it's
your turn
Pizza come on know about that water
layup I he will be fine it sounds like
oh yeah oh got a damn awesome yeah we
always crack the to help Ahmad to reach
the conclusion of this game of BP this
like they just hold in when you reach
this wanted it's complete chaos and at
some point you just go on 100% gut
instinct and sometimes seen pox punches
run wild and these qualifiers are rather
the group stages as well sent a weird
bender so that's typically not take your
space boy because you have like these
slow melee ekb wielding heroes I need
some North Americans on this panel with
me immediately for sure man I can do
that okay so my question to you now
Peter is just simply you know they're
going to be aggressive and no like you
know they're going to be attacking you
right on that's how you guys said right
on how do you respond
you play eg next you went oh into with
them a group stage what are some things
that you think you might need to do to
improve on to be ready to face them
again eg P gee I don't know it's going
to be rough for us because they're like
[__] they're Derek's a team like I'm
about some six rotate bottom of the
smoke we make this play they're going to
do this we do that three step model
excellent players overall maybe the most
convincing win of the day I guess that
was ah be next to it I think I hope that
liquid goes very welcome tomorrow yes I
was hoping VP will had had one today but
I didn't come from Brazil to see China
Winkie I so I hope they can make it to
the finals right we need a liquid face
what do we got here liquid oh the best
they'd be in secret it'd be an empire
you think Russians are going to stand in
our way and what we've done rosters
going to go to China
[Music]
[Laughter]
and of course best of all pepperonis his
favorite flavor that it truly is the
best piece of topping nothing like the
garbage pizza topping pineapple why ruin
a perfectly good pizza night come on are
you serious not pineapple shame up here
at the little let it go gosh why it does
so savory and salty put sweet on just
now you buy not a seam again but I've
actually gotten a chance to play the
game if you played previous trading card
games that has a lot of similarities in
terms of having creatures it sells which
is passed on to the board but in this
game anything you see in DotA it's here
there's not just one board with three
board you control five heroes deploy
them now SCC and I mean admittedly his
name is a horrible one four casters and
it does sound like a I don't know an
overly agreeable Spanish snake sdcc but
um that's all for joke that's why I'm
here on this panel let's talk about it
vote can you do a meepo voice because I
can do - I do ain't no problem some
tools and a good strong back cancel a
gig has got a dig huh a ridiculous
ability
they're really really taking and you
don't want to go up close to them at all
okay I say it's like a pack of really
hot girl that you can't can't can't be
impossible that's what kind of a nice
soccer to name that's not good there are
worse nicknames out there but there are
better ones to possibly the best and
worst one at the same time goes to Monet
because Monet and Chinese the way
they've said it is more nice hook which
in Chinese means something grabby
basically where are we going Jack where
you taking basically to a copper feel
upstairs
so that was severe sleeper that's like
when your dad's giving you the bag to
the base because sometimes playing
playing against link like around one
idea is much better it's like if you if
you were to punch someone you know you
punch someone with a finger or you know
one it doesn't matter if you have five
strong fingers if you go like this but
if you format this even you know even a
fist of weak your fingers feel better
than doing this right what's the [__]
are you talking about yeah
outstanding well we're learning a whole
lot more we'll be back in here inject
corner but for now we are going to jack
off and head over to shore and this is
where you get to see that I am the
master of Segway so after disruption
ends gonna spawn two little illusions
right next to them and then as for
disruptors going to appear right here in
the middle you probably wanted me to
draw something bit that's terrible
small things but like you said all these
this game is a game of inches all things
Adam excuse make the NC and PI cat who
are going to be the brains to I can say
my brawn it's not even wrong it's just
the brains to whatever I try and bring
to the table when how many inches is it
will excuse me ah so you break the ice
- Peter I think the first question is
you know VP you've said is what misery
everyone's well aware as I LGD they're
going to be coming expect they're going
to be attacking you in with in your face
oh yeah oh okay they can be attacking
you full frontal okay you know I'm say
that's what's going to be now I am I am
just I'm right yeah they're going to
come take on come on you yes come at you
various I guess is why we got another
panel sues your LGD looking incredibly
strong too very convincing matches as
times gone on Empire just looks so
cohesive and it was so strong I wonder
if he knew what he was doing when he
walked out on the stage and was like
everybody clapped for me as I defeated
the home team gosh it was a little
quieter than he was expecting I did okay
phasing in the glory of the Cross Q 3
Lea enjoying the like moment here on the
stage and penis and everything's just
basking in the glory yeah I guess it
just comes with you that someone
actually like shows emotions after they
ring and it's like super happening it's
like loving it yeah
so you thought John Cobb Van Dam sounded
cool and you said I got to be a little
bit more like that so Peter Pan dam and
I shortened it to PVD when I came to
dota because I need a cool three-letter
name like everybody right because then
it creates a little allure and mystery
and then they get that reward of
understanding jean-claude Van Damme's
it's not at all this is a great segment
of accessible conversation let's talk
about the teens or something around this
is you know what you have fighting stuff
again I think not Felix LAX's
interpretation was really inaccurate you
know real Apple what makes him qualified
to empathize with us audience here is
actually clapped to us Goyo
ladies and gentlemen ppb one of the top
15 panelists in the world here today
[Applause]
well done well done
Jimmer and think that you would climb
all the way to the pinnacle of the dota
2 community to be on this panel
did you that's right every three tape
player has his dreams
well it is my absolute pleasure to let
you know that game 3 between Team Liquid
and IG is beginning right now not now
it's not right now I lied to you and for
that I'm very sorry so let's just
continue to talk about drafting now
Shawn Bouldin so even though the playful
now I know and you know what
Jack's wrong bold is the best
confirmation panelists help me out bull
does not the best damn it he almost made
it out
say something that's like awkward
silence yeah I don't just click thoughts
on who you think is going to have an
edge in that matchup I think one of the
more entertaining things about that
matches for you what are we where we're
our VPS anyway like service Akasha maybe
going bottom with the intro editing you
know they want to avoid the confession
who do you ban against them it doesn't
matter Team Liquid always seem to have
an answer except for how to open this
champagne bottle that's going to be a
real challenge we're better than this
let's do it
champagne bottles are always a tricky
thing towards we're better than this you
know you can't open it they can win 3-0
in the grand final for the can't open a
champagne ball pinky just hold it it
bills on his hand yeah all right from
the bottle air ative okay well I'll have
to look depressing but thank you for
that all right if only fireball from
Jacques ghost on this minute instantly
goes into the TV they want to fail out
this one
Tim's fly up he does naturally have a
building to TP out this one as you'll
have to jump up to battle him if you
versus Tim who is king of the hill right
now University skip Alzheimer's or
people or get attendance the king of the
hill surviving eg they wanted something
in return
but they'll lose that all planar as well
it's stuck inside wording abroad he's
trying to get it it's there I cook it he
can't look it get the ball he actually
just can't click the agent I can't click
it I'm thinking is it still that
vernichtung in Malkin to you gets all
know what is happening the ball the
Smurfs were blowing green could he break
through the ages the ages didn't know
the ages is they get all I can't believe
who cos John again I just gonna get the
agent got the aegis we are the step what
is going on in this game the bet
they pretty much I have to get them in
the car like feel to kill him once you
zip once it gets online of course what
early on he's pretty weak does it what
do they think air is that final pic is
it going to be the same play they're
going to go for the alchemist so we'll
be the offlane boy do they also
understand though even with all this
initiation if ot have time to farm
operation this ah is he beating it with
this bindi be out that is so Envy like
ultra next level
I'm leaving the fight which is the
damage we required to actually win the
fight but we'll still win the fight
because there's enough Colton's the rest
acquired 9 to not kill offline who's
returning back 51 down to the ladonia
cold and brave he'll get a little bit of
level boy level for the vowels I'll
still kill offline I think this is the
first time I've seen someone spring TV
out of his own gang teams is so
formidable that neither team has
actually lost anyone as for needs of
blink out he doesn't have a BKB or blink
is 5xl and cool down for a minute and a
half he is dead out of this game for
over a hundred seconds solo solo
also the high ground pops the cheesy
fading spell he's not afraid right now
maybe he should be as Ramsay's engage in
and they're going to wait for him his
way on through finds another target
binds to thanking immediate by back but
it's the puggly who's dead without
buyback as well Mogi may be being
punished now for not having these 5x
they do get to kill in the yoga Anna
getting very low weight from back to the
high ground here he's in some trouble
cold embraces help seal it back up
they'd be forced by that kick in that
Anna goes down once will buy back
immediately like Anna's making taste it
right now DC I don't know if they
spotted on them moving over but they do
have a little bit of vision here and
with Perez moving in with the black hole
he blinked aggressively off to the side
they have it available thinking about
dropping it and indeed they are it
doesn't quite get on up bro what are you
doing about it coming back over the
close of another - are they expecting to
lose as a silence on the three that's
done as well you see you see what have
you done oh no no no no the great is
therefore no tail as well he's going to
be able to if you will scepter listen I
think he's still dead nonetheless but
that was not a play Kaiser is or always
just get the rollaway to get out of
there does have some stuff to throw out
a cannon scepters there's well the black
hole it's gone to nothing for him found
nobody but the global as well is it
going to be enough I don't think so abed
just trying to do what he can but
they've already lost Google as well and
the damage comes out j4 is gone but
three three fell hard to deal with as
well as that razor they're starting to
bring him low though and it's just four
too much damage Kaiser throws out the
sonic wave and they have lost their
sense again we've got each go just 2,700
cold I didn't even realize he was that
part I knew he was harmless yeah that's
taking it to another hole I mean I
nearly T thought that and probably for F
sake he would have preferred that I did
I think that was the sure it's black
hole of seen an alarm instantly council
caster and he is going to pay for his
sins as LF I clean him up I question
what happened down there
he like never came in when he thought he
was going to somebody's a bad thing
[Music]
what's the eraser in the decoupage
strong majority of fire I also think
it's important way better they'd
electing 15 mass pinging each other math
you just stole tomahtoes rude and then
also like Fisher blocked him it's a
region using room cleaning in playing
very very aggressively with what they
have or the more thing is joining for
these moves amount of clinical talk and
the baton still has to replicate hanging
around if they want to make it move
somewhere it's actually moving toward it
if that objects I'm up a trampoline
he's literally hit something it was a
replicant Bank easy grab on anybody's on
the side that's the important thing when
you're playing versus treiber's trial
and you have to watch your positioning
in to stay in the lane if you're gonna
do polls that's okay as long as if
somebody kind of guarding you fool but
for the most part you can't get caught
up by those crazy pics here's well this
mid-90s looking very good at the moment
super caught anybody is going to jump
fall for this was the point into waiting
ref did not really quite enough first in
fact a Duprey
Oh maybe should have stuck to playing
dragon nut but that is not how you want
to start on mid lane match other thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button
[Music]